Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Internet and my name is
today we're going to look at the
differences between Chinese and Chinese.
Well,
what I mean is we'll be looking at two
of the many Chinese languages,
Mandarin and Cantonese.
As I mentioned in my video on Chinese.
Chinese is not a single language,
but rather a number of dialect groups
that are united by a common writing
system.
The spoken languages are different and
generally mutually unintelligible,
which is definitely the case with
Mandarin and Cantonese,
which are both Semitic languages or
Chinese languages spoken in China.
Mandarin is spoken by 960 million native
speakers,
mainly in the north of China,
but as now used all over mainland China
and Taiwan as the official language of
government,
media and education,
and it's one of the four official
languages of Singapore as well.
Cantonese on the other hand is spoken by
50 to 60 million native speakers in Hong
Kong.
Macau go on zillow and some adjacent
areas as well as in Chinese diaspora
communities around the world.
It's part of the wider UAA branch of
Chinese.
Before we get into the main room.